[موسيقى]
الورود التي نزرعها هنا
لديهم أسماء كثيرة
اسمها العلمي روزا
santifolia ولكن يطلق عليه أيضًا
روز دي ماي اسمها روز دي ماي
لأنها تتفتح فقط في
قد لمدة 4 إلى 5 أسابيع و
ثم بقية الوقت جيدا الشجيرات
تفتح الزهرة أليس كذلك
إنها لعبة نارية تدوم كثيرًا
عملنا لفترة قصيرة
للمزارعين يبدأ بعد
تزهر وقت الإزهار
حان وقت العطلة تقريبًا
بالنسبة لنا لأن الانتقاء
عمل ليس إيماني كذلك
متعب لأنه لا يدوم إلا قليلاً
الوقت ، من ناحية أخرى ، عليك أن تعتني
خطط على مدار السنة
حتى تثري التربة التربة هنا
نحن نعمل على حوالي ثلاثة
هكتار ونصف من الأرض ولدينا
في الأرض شيء مثل 12000
الورود المستخدمة في الوردة
كثير في العديد من النكهات
على وجه الخصوص هذا هو المكان الذي هي فيه حقًا
أبرزت في Miss Dior ثم
في الغراء الأسود
[موسيقى]
أوه نعم من هذا القبيل
اتحاد كرة القدم
[موسيقى]
أود أن أقول ذلك إذا قرر كريستيان ديور
لاستثمار الكثير من الطاقة
العاطفة ثم المال أيضا من أجل هذا
مكان جميل لأن العائلة
ديور على الأقل والده والشاب
كاثرين ديور تأتي فاميليا
يستقر هنا في الشدائد و
كريستيان ديور يأتي بانتظام
زيارة عائلته في كاليان و أ
لحظة عندما يصبح ثريًا ومشهورًا
يريد شراء هذه القلعة الجميلة مقابل
البقاء على مقربة من أخته بالقرب من المكان
حيث قد تكون عائلته بأكملها قد أتوا
أفضل هدية يمكن للأخ
ما يفعله لأخته هو تكريس أ
عطر باقة من الزهور الخالدة
شاركت كاثرين ديور خلال
الحرب من أجل بلدها وكانت
توقفت كانت في حالة تحرك
نازي تم القبض عليها
رحلت عانت الكثير و
عندما عادت من المخيم
عمل ما بعد الحرب
عندما يقوم أخيه بإنشاء ملف
أول مجموعة أزياء وفي نفس الوقت
في المرة الأولى التي يبحث فيها عن عطر
الاسم وهو يخصصه لكاثرين
هي تفتقدها الآنسة ديور لذا هي
هي التي تقف وراء هذا العطر الرائع
[موسيقى]
وأنا في دوري كمدير للمقصورة
المكياج ثم الآخرين ل
تصفيفة الشعر لميشيل جوبت للموسيقى
بيتا للديكور الذي تراه كلنا
هناك نحن جميعًا هنا لإكمال هذا
رؤية
[موسيقى]